hey youtubers it's Charlie so yesterday
during my Game of Thrones video I asked
you to submit all of the questions so
here we shall answer them I also saw a
little bit of evidence for winds of
winter release so I'll talk about that
first it involves a little bit of math
and a little bit of leaked information
from an international news site
collectively they're saying spring 2015
which I don't think is gonna happen but
they did a science website 538 ran their
own stats based on some known factors
and came up with February 2015 day based
on their model George r Martin would
have to hit his maximum word count every
day each day until that February 2015
date and he already took a break to go
to the Edinburgh Book Festival the
international news site I mentioned
supposedly it's called book keep library
is saying April 2015 which would be the
start of season 5 I can't even find
their website so I can't confirm where
they got that April date from 538 is
Nate Silver's website so I mean they're
pretty reliable but their data doesn't
really take into account real-world
factors but they can't factor in George
are Martin getting invited to go to
other festivals which he does very often
if you've never heard about him talk
about how he writes he basically only
does it when he does not travel like he
doesn't write when he travels and drink
football season he takes every Sunday
off but otherwise he does write every
day personally I'd like to see wins a
winner by the end of season 5 that'd be
like June 2015 I still think that's
fairly optimistic but I don't think it's
gonna happen
you think they try to line it up with
the season 5 finale but book releases
don't work that way HBO and his
publisher are two completely different
companies I don't even want to think
about book 7 Martin it originally
planned for seven books dream of spring
being the last one but now he's talked
about expanding that last book in an
additional book so there could be eight
books there just be more side characters
and more plots going on around the main
characters I will do a separate winds of
winter video at some point and just talk
more about these things so be sure to
subscribe to get it
but I do expect wins a winner in 2015
sometime but it'll probably be like
November okay so onto questions so these
are all small try to read them Rebecca
asks when the faceless men changed does
it have to be a different face each time
I'd love to see Jack and hook are again
so what they do is they cure faces like
they preserve them and they wear them
like masks so yes they could always go
back to old faces the first time I read
the book and then I saw the series I was
confused but the book explains it much
better theoretically jaqen has the face
he was born with we don't know if that's
the one that we saw in the series but he
could totally go back to that after
wearing other people's faces it's also
important to note that if they're on a
mission to kill someone or infiltrate
some place they can kill a new person
take their face and then walk around as
said person that's why a lot of people
think that Syrio Forel might be jaqen
H'ghar i don't think that's the case I
think it was just a coincidence but I am
hoping that Dan and Dave understand how
much the fans talk about this and at
least conclude some sort of Easter Egg
for during the Bravo scenes in season 5
and just explain the taking of people's
faces so like if Jenkins on a mission
and he sees someone and he kills them he
takes their face like he literally cuts
their face off cures it preserves it so
it doesn't decompose and then wears it
as a mask so they're basically wearing
masks on - question number two John
Smith asks what do you think about the
Dornish master plan and the HBO show do
you think that they'll address it or do
you think the show won't address it at
all
so I think the show is just gonna
simplify it just so it's much easier to
understand for people that do not read
the books what they'll probably do is
have Alexander siddig who's playing
Teran seem like a weak person because of
his gout and then after the sand snakes
cause a bunch of trouble
surprise surprise he'll get that I will
be your champion type moment that Oberyn
had drinks season four you have to think
about the way the show initially
presented Oprah and I think they're
gonna kind of do the same type of thing
so when Tyrion is talking about him in
that first episode of season four he
makes him seem like a more horse version
of Jaime just screwing his way across
the world then you get to know him a
little bit better and we find out that
he's cunning leading up to the scene in
the black cells where he reveals his
revenge plan to Tyrion I think it's
gonna play out in a similar type of way
like they're gonna tease Prince to ran
out like he'll seem weak and indecisive
cut to you know I have a plan I've
always had a plan and things are going
according to my plan nicely like things
are going the way I want them to it just
seems like a very TV type thing to do
they'll just cut out a lot of the
details from the book version just to
make the master plan simpler I am so
excited about Alexander siddig I was a
huge fan of Deep Space nine especially
after dr. Bashir got super dark during
the whole JEM Hadar war moving out to
question number three
Julian Parisi sorry Charlie here comes
my second question I didn't see her
first one so no worries consider
the show almost did not use the
character Lyanna stark do you think that
the producers already know that the
theory r plus l equals j is not correct
so i don't think that there's really any
evidence to say that that's not correct
there's no way the show would confirm or
deny a big reveal like that this soon in
the series that's like season 7 stuff
even the books have danced around Jon
Snow's mother I've already done like a
couple of mega theory videos for who I
think Jon Snow's mother is in the logic
behind that so I'll include links in the
description at the end of the video if
you guys want to watch that right now in
my opinion there has been no theory with
more compelling evidence than R + L
equals J just because the show hasn't
cast Lyanna stark yet or done a big
flashback sequence doesn't mean they
won't you have to remember they're
planning for eight seasons so there is a
lot of stuff that they just have not
gotten to yet on the other side of that
though if you guys feel like you have
better evidence for a competing theory
about Jon Snow's mother please write it
in the comments it's a really fun topic
to talk about it because nobody knows
you know book readers and show readers
it's not really spoilery so it's not too
hard to talk about on to question number
four no Gallagher asks do we know how
jaqen H'ghar was captured in the first
place and why was he being sent to the
wall with Arya I actually saw a lot of
questions about jack ins whereabouts in
season 2 the simple answer is is that he
was exactly where he wanted to be like
he wanted to go to the wall so he let
himself be captured
hopefully the show and the books will
explain it in greater detail but I think
he placed himself in Arya's path I don't
think that it's any kind of confirmation
that Jack and in Syria the same person
but I think that he saw Arya in King's
Landing took an interest in her and
thought she had potential as a future
faceless person I think it's just a
combination of circumstance and design
Jack and didn't go to King's Landing
just because of Arya but once he was
there he saw her and called an audible
on whatever mission he was on book 5
does provide some suggestions as to his
whereabouts and what he's doing so if
you want to know more about that just
read you know it is a bit spoilery so if
you do want to comment about it and if
you read the books just please use
spoiler tags question number five Steve
salmon asks do you think that
Littlefinger and Sansa are going to get
married and gain the armies of the north
and the amazing george RR martin hinted
about killing tyrion so who is or who
will be the third head of the dragon
so as for your second question no I
don't think that he's gonna kill Tyrion
at least in wins a winner I don't think
he's gonna die anytime
soon I know everyone wants Tyrion to be
the focal point for the battle between
the forces of the great other and the
red God I do think he's gonna die
eventually just it's not gonna happen in
wins a winter the way I think about it
is that no one on the series gets a
happy ending they'll just get an ending
people find themselves in new situations
and they either adapt or die so at the
end of the series most of the people
that are still alive from the show right
now will look completely different
they'll be completely different
personalities and to answer your
question about a little finger and Sansa
Littlefinger actually explains his plan
in the books I think the show is just
gonna do the Sansa stuff without
changing that too much it's a pretty
simple situation that they present but
just read the Sansa chapters and it'll
explain everything I am really excited
to see Sansa in season 5 because sophie
Turner said that she's gonna have like
some life Awakening moments like some
really big events in her life on to
question number six Andrew you asks I'm
asking this being a TV watcher but who
do you think may assassinate Tommen and
who will take down the Lannisters it's
almost like things are just gonna keep
going downhill I assume when you say TV
watcher you mean you just haven't read
the books I don't think that Tommen is
gonna be assassinated I think it'd be
too predictable if they killed Tom and
so quickly after setting him up as a
totally normal kid that doesn't mean
that he won't be killed and if he does
get killed I don't think that Tyrion is
gonna be the one to do it
but yes things are totally going
downhill in King's Landing and it's
gonna be so much fun to watch on the
show Tyrion left with Varys and Tywin is
dead
that makes Cersei the person in charge
which is what she always wanted but
she's a terrible person and probably a
terrible ruler so I am really excited to
see things fly out of control question
number seven Canter's asks do you think
that it's likely in the series Jen drew
will be in Braavos and reunited with
Arya I would be so disappointed they
just completely dropped kendrys
storyline it is totally possible that
they could never mention him again
unless they've changed the books and
combined some characters which they do
quite a bit actually but if we look at
the possibilities he could have rode his
boat into the Narrow Sea and been picked
up by a merchant ship heading to the
east so he could be in the East even if
he's not in Braavos and when we think
about Arya storyline at the end of
season 4 it seemed like she was leaving
everything she knew behind like she was
becoming a new person so I think
bringing in like old characters from her
past would put the brakes on that so I
don't think that it's gonna happen right
away if she does run into Gendry there
have been a whole bunch of characters
that have been separated by
circumstances since season
I do think at a certain point a lot of
them will cross paths again but we still
got like four more seasons to go so it
might be a while but if you remember
Brienne ran into hot pie I think we'll
see a lot more scenes like that
question number eight Tamar asks if I
was gonna start reading the books which
one should I start with I've never read
any of them before but I read a lot and
I loved the series so I get this
question a lot congratulations you will
not regret reading the books reading is
very important I treat it as a very
important thing in Game of Thrones is an
amazing book series Song of Ice and Fire
if you want to skip everything that's
already happened just start with book
for the last scene in season four with
aria is right where book 4 begins they
did spill into book 4 for a few
characters but for all intents and
purposes book 4 is going to comprise the
greatest portion of season 5 after that
if you want you know you can circle back
around and read all the first three
books or if you just have a ton of time
on your hands and you read really fast
just start with the first book and read
all of them you basically have till the
beginning of April before season 5 gets
here question number 9 gary johnson asks
are you gonna be doing character
previews for season 5 like you did for
season 4 so i don't think i'm gonna be
doing the exact same thing but i am
trying to change things just a little
bit just to make it better I usually try
to alter the way I do videos based on
what everyone enjoys the most so a lot
of it just depends on requests I get
from you guys like people asking for
more explainer videos or book theory
videos or history videos since I quit my
job I also have a ton more time to write
so what your pricey is me asking people
to vote on topics and then just me doing
whichever video gets voted on the most
I'm also really excited to try videos
that involve things that you guys
contribute like that's the ultimate goal
to make videos involving you guys you
know whether it be through art that you
submit or theories you have or just
something funny you say like that's what
I'm trying to figure out how to do right
now so like the videos I do will largely
be the same but the way I make them will
change quite a bit and question number
tenten last one Charo Jack asks my
question is do you think the high
Sparrow is really Howland Reed in
disguise we haven't seen him in the
books of the show and he's not dead and
he's the only other person with Ned at
the Tower of pleasure so he's too
important to be on the sidelines so I
don't think that they're the same person
you know Howland Reed is described as
being like a very small person and he's
closer to Ned's age and the high Sparrow
is Jonathan Pryce
you know he's a much older person Helen
reads actually a really interesting
character so I'm definitely hoping this
series does him he saved Ned Stark's
life by holding off Arthur Dayne and
he's obviously like you said the only
other person besides Ned to survive
whenever they went to rescue Lyanna
Stark from Rhaegar Targaryen at the
Tower of joy for those that haven't read
the books Howland Reed is the father of
Jojen and Meera Reed he's a crannogmen
so he lives in the hills near Winterfell
on the show so far he's basically just
been hiding out up in the hills while
the crazy stuffs been going on in
Westeros and in the east and for book
readers there's also a really good
theory that he is the knight of the
Laughing tree so far I haven't seen any
casting notices for characters that fit
his description but I really am hoping
that the show does him at some point but
thank you so much for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do
there were a lot of spoiler questions
that I tried to answer in the comments
directly I don't mind answering spoilery
questions but sometimes if they're too
spoilery I just try to keep it in the
comments and for anyone who didn't catch
me talking about it before please make
sure that replies are turned on for your
comments whenever you leave comments you
should see the little reply icon below
your comment otherwise I can't answer
you and congratulations to this week's
book giveaway winner Nicholas Bauer you
basically win your choice of any George
are Martin Game of Thrones book it could
be one of the short stories to paperback
or Kindle I'll be messaging you on your
channel for details since there were so
many questions about religions and gods
in my last video I think my next bonus
video is going to be an explainer for
all the major religions in the series
they're all really interesting in the
next round of the giveaway will start
whenever I post that video remember for
the giveaways all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and just leave
a comment on the videos that's as simple
as that while you wait for that video
you can click here to learn about my
favorite game of Thrones theories and
you can click here for my latest Doctor
Who starter guide remember Doctor Who
episode 1 is this Saturday so get ready
thank you so much watching I'll see you
guys tonight
high fives
you